let's get to audience questions for the week.
Some good ones I'm looking forward to answering.
Remember to send me yours of via email is
best. David pakman.com use the contact form.
Title should be audience question
and maybe it'll be answered on an upcoming
show. David, who is more guilty of a plane
crash? Donald Trump or Walter White? I actually
like this because it does allow us to think
about this plane crash a thing in a slightly
different terms. So the setup is after Donald
Trump decided to have Aramean crudes leader
Kaseem Solemani assassinated Iran, shot down
a Ukrainian passenger plane, which was from
Iran to Ukraine, killing everyone on board.
Iran initially denied responsibility, ultimately
had no choice but to admit it. Yes, Iran shot
down a fully loaded passenger plane. The argument
that some have put forward is, doesn't Trump
have some responsibility for the plane crash?
Because if Trump hadn't assassinated Qassim
Soleimani none of it would have happened,
which has a couple of problems. Number one
is that it totally takes agency away from
Iran as a player that can discern whether
something in the sky is a passenger plane
or not.
Why did Iran decide not to stop all air traffic
knowing that they were going to be engaged
in this bombing campaign? So when you look
at the causality chain, you can say, well,
the, the, the, the catalyst was Trump assassinating
Solemani Trump wouldn't have been in a, in
a position to make that call. Uh, if Hillary
Clinton had been president. So don't we need
to blame the people who voted for Donald Trump?
Hey, let's go back even further. Uh, what
about the parents of the people who birth
the voters that voted for Donald Trump? The
point is you can find a reasonable place to
draw the line in terms of the causality chain,
but it can always be argued to be different.
Now, the comparison here is Walter White in
what is arguably one of the best television
series in history. Breaking bad. Walter White
caused a plane to crash in a sort of similar
sense in breaking bad.
As I remember, I'm trying, I'm going from
memory here. It's been awhile since I watched
it. Watch the show. Walter White and Jesse
Pinkman were partners making a cooking meth
and Jesse Pinkman was dating a girl whose
father happened to be an air traffic controller.
The girl became addicted to meth. Uh, the
very meth that Walter White and Jesse Pinkman.
We're cooking thanks to being in this relationship
with um, a Jessie pink pen. She had ready
access to plenty of it. She overdosed and
as she was overdosing, Walter White showed
up, saw her overdosing, saw her starting to
choke on her own vomit and made the decision
to let her die because she, he believed he
made the call that it would be better for
his business. Clearly a better for his avoiding
law enforcement. If Jesse Pinkman his girlfriend
were allowed to die rather than saving her
from this overdose in his grief about his
daughter's death, the girl's dad, the air
traffic controller, um, make some mistake
while working and causes a midair collision
of two planes killing everybody on board.
So the question is, well, okay, what is the
responsibility there versus Trump, which is
seemingly more direct? Trump assassinated
Solemani and this led directly to Iran shooting
down a passenger plane. Now there were some
very good comments about this on a sub Reddit
discussion on our subreddit about this one
was of the specific plane crash. Both are
equally guilty, but Trump is more guilty of
the loss of life since his actions were more
likely to cause additional deaths. Then Walter
White allowing Jesse Pinkman, his girlfriend
to overdose and die. Uh, another comment,
Iran general got killed with a drone strike
and Iran shoots down the very first aircraft
that seems to veer off course when they suspect
it's a U S missile. The chain of causality
is like one ring long suggesting Trump is
far more responsible. But again, it takes
away agency from Iran. Iran is the one that
was unable to, I guess, distinguish that this
was a passenger airplane and not a U S missile.
Another comment from the subreddit, neither
is guilty of the plane crash. Neither could
reasonably have foreseen that their actions
would lead to plane crashes. In law, we would
say each plane crash was too remote. A consequence
of the actions of both Walter White and Donald
Trump. They were not natural consequences.
Therefore, neither is guilty of a plane crash.
What do you think? I tend to go with the latter,
which is that plane crashes are not reasonably
expected outcomes to allowing someone to overdose
from meth or assassinating Kaseem. Solemani
let me know
what
you think.